[Applause]
all right tonight Titans bore on
appliances is ramping up now according
to new reports he is now targeting your
gas furnace now with restrictions that
would prohibit 40 to 60 percent of the
residential furnaces that are currently
on the market now furnaces are only the
latest Target of these Biden bands and
by the way that means you'll all be
paying more for your furnace and
remember he also wants to ban your gas
stove and your dishwasher and your gas
powered car and your light bulbs and
your jewels and your washing machines
and your air conditioning and did I
mention your Jewels don't take away my
Jewel anyway here with reaction
Louisiana Senator uh John Kennedy
I might be a little old-fashioned
Senator and and I lived in the South uh
I wasn't raised there like you are but I
lived in Alabama and I lived in Georgia
some of the best years of my life some
of the nicest people I met and then
including in your state and with all due
respect I believe in a concept called
freedom and I don't need the federal
government taking my stove my air
conditioner uh or any of these other
appliances and I want them to get the
hell out of my life is that
old-fashioned
no I think that's that's American
um all of them
all of this is just one further
indication
that the Biden Administration has a
Fatal Attraction
to uh to nutty ideas
about 50 percent
of American households Heat their homes
with natural gas powered furnaces
President Biden's new rule would make
about 40 to 60 percent of those furnaces
illegal because he doesn't think they
are sufficiently energy efficient
um the bad Administration Sean is also
beavering away on similar rules as you
pointed out for gas stoves for ovens for
for dishwashers for clothes dryers for
electric motors for vending machines
all of this is going to hurt the
American people it's going to restrict
consumer Choice it's going to raise
prices and it's going to have minimal if
any impact on co2 emissions
um
in my opinion it's a moron-a-thon
uh and and it is just it is just further
evidence that crazy never takes a day
off in Washington D.C when President
Biden's in charge
it's also it's also going to be very
unpopular particularly the price Rises
uh polling uh clearly shows fairly or
unfairly that a majority of Americans
think that President Biden is on a day
pass from the nursing home
and
and and further further polling shows
that at the moment the president is
about
he's about as popular as a colonoscopy
and
and I just don't think
I don't understand the politics of all
of this it's going to be extraordinarily
unpopular and just have a minimal impact
on our environment
Senator I got to ask you do you actually
write these things or this whole
extemporaneous I I I'm guessing it's
extemporaneous let me read you the
exhaustive list of what he wants to ban
starting with with gas stoves uh
dishwashers gas stoves furnaces fossil
fuels gas powered cars even though
electric vehicles cost about 20 grand
more and are powered by an electric grid
that is 90 fossil fuels side note a
washing machines light bulbs fridge
assault weapons ghost guns nine
millimeters lead ammunition uh mining in
The Boundary Waters and more drilling
air conditioners and did I mention
Jewels yes
um I will tell you something Senator the
average person cannot afford to replace
all of these expensive appliances with
more expensive appliances the average
electric vehicle is 15 to 20 grand more
and by the way you have to pillage
Mother Earth to get the Cobalt and the
manganese and the nickel to build those
complicated batteries that are heavy
that'll ultimately be powered by fossil
fuels
look
clearly President Biden has a blind spot
for the lives and concerns of ordinary
Americans all of these rules which will
increase prices as you pointed out Sean
are on top of the inflation that the
Biden Administration caused in my state
Louisiana because of President Biden's
inflation the average family is having
to pay
740 dollars a month not a year a month
more that's almost nine thousand dollars
a year
and uh and now they're going to make all
of their appliances more expensive so so
when the bad Administration said if you
I remember their press conference when
they said if you like your gas stove you
can keep your gas stove they lied yeah
like keep your doctor keep your care uh
keep your plan and save money I never
panned out either the great Senator
Kennedy from Louisiana thank you sir hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else